John Barry former NBA veteran handling a
pregame halftime postgame duties ESPN
radio throughout the NBA Finals and John
joins us on the program and he surprises
us last night for you know you and the
Donets coulda beat that warrior team I
think wow no I mean really how do you
lose two of your top four players three
of your top eight players if you count
come on loading it there and it's been a
major contributor in the playoffs no I'm
not surprised at all I mean they should
and when Toronto should have won that
game and they did I said it was a
must-win situation for Toronto for a
variety of reasons John I don't know if
you agree but I just thought if you
can't beat that lineup then you're not
winning the finals but you did what you
were supposed to do last night they did
it in impressive fashion how do you
think this plays out now if I said you
got a bet a week's pay on who wins the
championship knowing what we know now
who would you take well what do we know
do we know Clay's back and we don't know
just well I know right now okay well I
think he's going to be back I before it
started if Kevin Durant doesn't play in
the series that Toronto wins it okay so
I stand by that it could be a total
smokescreen that Kevin Durant is ramping
up his workouts and he's ready to go he
might not be playing at all we don't
know anything but I do believe clay was
back he really wanted to play last night
he could have had it been a Game seven
situation he would have been out there
but I still believe Toronto will win
this series because I don't know that
Kevin Durant comes back and even if he
does you know you know there's no you
know they're gonna have to completely
play differently and you know I did a
calf two at the end of my career and you
compensate and you get some left knee
problems and you know there's there's
there's no guarantee Kevin Durant will
be the Kevin Durant that we've come to
watch for this you know all these years
how would you describe Steph Curry's
performance if somebody didn't see it
last night man he's I don't understand
why these guys
and as he is he's incredible and to me
he's the system of the Warriors I don't
get my Durant is a great player a great
scorer and Steph Curry he's he's as
unique a player as I've ever seen
because why do you think he's malign
John I don't understand I hate lying on
reading they're saying that the his
peers don't respect him and I don't know
is it a jealousy thing because he's a
model citizen and he's a great family
man and he's a great player and he is a
hell of a golfer and lives a great life
I mean I'll take it I mean but what you
know if you're jealous doesn't mean you
should hate I mean it's the guy's an
incredible person and he's uh he's a
great basketball player and like I said
Lee
you always say well this kind of reminds
me of him even like yeah who does Steph
Curry run Europe nobody he stopped curly
he's changed the game yeah I think the
only comp might be and it's and it's not
fair to either one is there's there's a
lot of Nash in curry
you know Steve didn't have that range
and he didn't and he always passed first
you know they the Suns you know they had
to tell him to shoot more because he
just he wasn't that kind of player
whereas Steph doesn't need to be told
but I think that you know Nash and
courier similar and Kerr even says that
he looked at Nash and loved his game and
tried to emulate a lot of that I agree
yeah
but stuff clearly much more of a scoring
mentality Dennis Davis Steve was a great
shooter I mean these are 50 49z guy yeah
I'm not many guys in the league have
done it but what Steve did it yeah but
the the scoring ability to range the off
the dribble
the handle you know Steph Curry's in the
class of his own talking to John Barry
the mothership ESPN radio pre halftime
postgame duties for ESPN Radio
throughout the NBA Finals McLovin
brought this up where some people are
talking about Steve Kerr is he one of
the great coaches of all time and I said
it's a little early for that
you know coronation here but it is Steve
Kerr one
great coaches of all time John well I
don't know if we can go there I'm with
you what if they don't win this final
and school two in this five-year run
what does this mean for for their legacy
of this team I mean five years we
haven't seen it right since the sixties
straight five straight finals we would
have with the Bulls let's face it if
Michael Jordan didn't leave for two
years
but three and two you know a draymond
Green suspension and they'd probably win
that title and then this year obviously
if they don't get it done they'll be
Asterix with the injuries so I think is
an incredible run I think he's an
incredible coach but yeah I think we
have to see a little more than a
five-year stretch is it better for the
NBA if the Raptors win or the Warriors
win I don't know it's not good for ESPN
ratings at Toronto and but III do think
people are kind of tired of the Warriors
and you know it's good to have some
fresh blood in there it's exciting but
we didn't do this with the Bulls John I
don't think anybody was tired of the
bull why why do we get tired and
warriors yeah yeah you're right I well I
mean is it the Michael Jordan effect
like I can't get tired of watching
Michael Jordan but how can I get tired
of watching Steph Curry cuz you're
jealous of them and you hate him no I'm
not tired of why I love watching Steph
Curry no I know
I am jealous I don't know maybe it's
social media that you had no social
media back then with the Bulls and does
that change anything of people
constantly talking about things where's
everything is on social media with you
know with Golden State yeah I think so
you know and maybe the camera guy ran in
fact I think people are upset that one
of the great players are joined a great
team already but you know if you want to
talk that argument they won one title
before Kevin Durant got there they won
73 games and they didn't win the title
so they had two straight Finals
appearances of any so
so yeah I know they were great and they
ran through the league in the regular
season and won one title but you know it
wasn't like he joined Michael Jordan of
the bowls and each two for two
I think how do you think Jordan's Bulls
would do with today's rules against
Golden State
well I mean how do you go over Michael
Jordan I mean it'd be impossible okay
it'd be so fun to watch you know and
then you put you know like we've heard
Scottie Pippen talk about it let him on
Steph Curry though like that's a lot of
length and I mean if you can switch you
just have Dennis Rodman switch on to
Steph Curry Ron Harper
they had length on the perimeter link
yeah yeah I mean it yeah a lot of fun I
wish we could check it out but I don't
think it's gonna happen yeah I would be
like draymond Green on John Jordan like
who's guarding Jordan maybe Golden State
would do a box oh yeah that's true
you know they they miss him last night I
mean this disc Golden State defense just
got shredded I mean 123 points and 17
threes come on Oh makes and you know
it's Kawhi Leonard and his others are
far better than Steph Curry and his
others certainly last night yeah I like
SIOC him a lot do you think that he can
be that number 2 guy like that every
night you can count on him or is he
still a little green here yeah I think a
little bit of work you know not a real
great jump shooter it's terrific athlete
a lot of the stuff comes out in
transition but yeah I think there's a
possibility to develop that that he can
become you know a standstill shooter I
got I can shoot off the dribble play
one-on-one buddies you know more of a
slasher right now but you know Game one
obviously the game of his life didn't
play well in Game two and then bounce
back last night had a nice one how do
these kids grow up not being able to
shoot and then you have in it but you
have players like there there's no
excuse for anybody who is you know five
- you know 18 years of age who doesn't
have a with Steph Curry
his impact on this game but you've got
some of the better players in the game
who can't shoot yeah we don't like then
we'll go right to Ben Simmons like well
how your dad played professionally I
believe how does he allow you to have
your elbow going you know horizontally
when did lately
Wow I understand it's like I think I
taught my kids how to eat with a fork to
like it's basically the same thing I
mean you learn how to do it the correct
way but even the gret you know
basketball coach Lavar ball you would
think he would have been able to teach
his son how to shoot a jump shot here
right yeah I guess but he's not too far
off and I remember he reminds me so much
of Jason's hit and like I guess that's
why they brought him in there but Jason
Kidd didn't have the prettiest jump shot
either and he's I think in the top three
of threes made in the crook in the
history of the NBA so Ron's I'll get it
do you think he stays there I don't
where's he go no do you think he's
headed to New Orleans well yeah there's
you know could be a three-way type thing
where maybe Phoenix jumps in or
something but uh yeah I think he's gonna
be on his way and and I like him a lot I
think he's gonna be an excellent player
in this league I like him too I like him
a lot he has a great feel for the game
it's just you know he's he's a liability
on the product why do you have to play
with LeBron he doesn't it's a bad mix
from the beginning exactly exactly like
the whole the whole roster they had is a
bad mix all not the whole roster but
most of it I mean you guys they don't
need a basketball I could stand there
and shoot when you play with LeBron
James and they didn't have many of those
guys John good to talk to you you played
golf out there in the Bay Area you've
gone to San Francisco Club maybe this
little night cutting oh that's it no I'm
going to the golf club in about two
hours and that San Francisco Golf Club
is one of the core favorites in the
world well I think frisky for the wake
up call it's always nice John thanks we
appreciate it but you got alright
I'm Barry ESPN Radio NBA analyst and
he's a good stick to as we like to say
in golf terminology he's a good stick
John can play for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]